>> I think India has a very good chance of
becoming a superpower simply
by the fact that its diverse population, its
diverse knowledge base,
the education levels, peoples' IT skills that
have been shown around
the world, the medical facilities that are
available and the medical
field that has reached around the world has,
has taken India to already
what it is today.
And I think if that has -- that skill -- those
skills are honed in
education and by educating as many of its
population as possible, I
think India can easily become a superpower.
It has the financial means and it has the
educational -- the base that
requires.
I think India in the next 15 years is aligned
to reach that level.
Easily.